so you're developing an app and of
course that app is innovative and
groundbreaking it has huge potential and
if it's as successful as you expect it
may one day exceed the limits of
traditional systems you'll need a no
sequel database that is fast simple to
maintain and scales from gigabytes to
petabytes with no downtime that's where
Google Cloud BigTable comes into play
cloud BigTable is a fully managed
service meaning you can concentrate on
your app instead of tuning your database
with its unique combination of low
latency and high throughput cloud
BigTable can scale to reliably handle
massive workloads at lightning-fast
speeds and up to millions of operations
per second with no reconfiguration
downtime customers are using cloud
BigTable today for a range of
applications from real-time ad analytics
all the way to tracking millions of
readings from thousands of IOT sensors
and because cloud BigTable is compatible
with industry standard tools like HBase
Hadoop and Google bigquery and cloud
dataflow it means it's easy to put all
that data to work for your app Google
Cloud BigTable this super fast highly
scalable no sequel database your app
needs today and tomorrow